for B Stars how did you go about
animating like animal characters and
giving them like the same
animalistic character uh animalistic
characters that each I guess animal has
so B stars um we start from I mean they
have human traits as animals yeah so
what's the balance between that so
um we started looking at the what it
called the
anatomy yeah so how does animal muscle
facial structure happen why do animals
not smile
how can we make these creatures smile
right right was the first starting point
so you literally went he literally had
to break down each animal's Anatomy did
that go into like the modeling of all of
the characters as well oh my God I mean
like if animals don't have this muscle
and this muscle right so they can't make
um the rich Expressions humans it's
impossible for them all right so yeah
because I guess that must have been like
a like an uncanny valley that would have
been difficult to overcome because it's
like if you just added those muscles
into the model then I'm sure like the
first couple of like prototypes must
have looked like super janky right yeah
yeah how much research did you have to
do in each animal before even like
modeling I mean that's that's the reason
three years
yeah so yet three years of research yeah
I mean two years of research two years
of research Jesus just I mean research
is just in books or photos or videos but
also research uh actually putting into
model and it's working working is this
three years after like hey we've signed
a contract being like let's make the
show we've been we've been uh brought in
to do this you know how do you then
explain I assume to like a client it's
got to be kind of tough to be like hey
just give them a little while they're
just figuring things out like how does
that all conversation go I mean that's
the conversation we have to have for
Trigon yeah you're just like hey just
trust me we're gonna figure it out
oh I mean try gun um we since a producer
for a trident on our client side his
producer who worked for Nan ushers and
he starts we knew each other yeah so we
had a lot of very mutual trust and we're
not going to hide stuff we're showing
him yeah this is the process we're doing
right now yeah how much do you kind of
like need to network as an anime
producer in terms of meeting other
people in the industry
um as of I used to be a hand-drawn site
right but Henry on Thai was demented
because I had to collect every single
animator myself too oh geez not every
single but a lot of the key figures yeah
yeah but for Orange um production we all
of our animates are in-house okay so I
don't have to do that on that side it's
to me who am I going to find for the key
staff so the scriptwriter director
um episode director and such so is that
in-house as well
okay so you literally have to like go
out to the industry and see who is
available to work on this one show for
these specific roles yes why wouldn't
you have those people in-house like
what's the benefit
some people we have in-house but each
project gets so different I mean what's
required so different art style is
different storytelling is different
makes sense so right okay how
how accurate is shiribako I've always
because like as an anime viewer when we
talk about anime production you know
there is a lot more resources out right
now but to like I say someone who's not
too deep into the field a lot of people
look at shirabaka as being like this is
this is a documentary base yeah yeah
I've had so many instances of someone
like giving me like a tidbit on like oh
this is how the anime production works
and I'm like what's your source and
they're like shirabaka episode seven and
I'm like okay but maybe some of it is
like dramatized so yeah yeah I mean
papers I mean he's using as hurricanes
as of course it's a fiction
um I mean I was never involved in
shirogo itself yeah I mean it's a lot of
the Israel so and we're driving to pick
up um animation from animators we see
other Studio rival Studios we do stare
at each other like this and like start
revving the end
I mean we all we all make sure that we
are not
just like scary
Michael feels so exciting and real
because that is based on a lot of
people's experience yeah is is it normal
for like an episode to be finished just
before it like airs on TV uh for our
case I mean that's not the style we
choose anymore yeah but I mean in my
past um career I have had that kind of
situation as we got was it like pretty
often or was it like kind of like a
one-off
I I could call it often
oh no who's got the good PC to render
this end
I had a time where I thought how I
comfortably sleep at the studio was an
amazing thing but I I'm really glad now
that I don't have to sleep at a studio
at all so that's good that's good did
you have to sleep like you got to do
previous roles did you have to sleep
there how often did you have to sleep at
the studio well I mean cardboard is
comfortable oh no
sleeping bag on the cardboard is even
more comfortable
sleeping under a meeting desk is really
comfortable because there's no light
coming on oh no so get this episode out
I haven't seen my wife in three days how
much is like the office would uh you
know obviously in the past how much of
the office like percentage-wise would
end up just sleeping at the office
percentage percentage is difficult
because I mean everyone's doing
different jobs yeah yeah yeah but like
you must feel like a giant sleepover if
everyone's at the end I mean there's
certain a couple couches that's in the
studio okay sometimes it was a fight to
get that cuts too
I recently filmed something at a
different Anime Studio
um and I I turned up at like 3 P.M to
film something and uh it was people
people were coming in just from waking
up and I was like what they just woke up
it's 3pm I mean that could be that might
not not necessarily be overworking I
mean yeah the whole just like living
I didn't get that impression but I got
the impression of like oh it's it's
animators they work on their own time
yeah yeah the sleep schedule is a
suggestion but it gets done it gets done
you don't have to be awake while
everyone else is awake as long as you
get you worked on you get those eight
hours and you get those animations done
who cares I mean now those things are
becoming digital so yeah assistance
going in cars but back then cars was a
thing so
um if there's traffic that means we have
to spend more time yeah
so like I guess you don't have to like
like name any names or anything like
that but like
when when an anime production does go
wrong you know when when you see the
final product and it's not like not
necessarily Studio orange just in
general the anime industry what goes
into what mistakes go into
uh uh like an anime production that
might not have the final products that
the people working on it want to have
like because it seems like a lot of it
is from the planning stages and I'm
curious yeah what actually what actually
goes wrong in that sense there's
thousands of array of things that needs
to be careful about instant production
right so honestly um as a production
management
um
the amount of information that you have
to manage is a very
very intense trial I think even missing
one of them will can be led to that you
need to give some examples of what kind
of like information
it's like scheduling or it's been a
while so I tried to remember my memory
yeah because it's I'm like as an anime
producer I'm sure you have to like
manage a lot of different things so
how long how long has has it been since
you joined orange again it's been five
years for me okay five years so cool
enough to make one show
I mean covert did special thing to me it
kind of like a lot of my memory before
that's that's Humanity that's just
Humanity the symptoms of like long
coveted you like a memory gets worse is
it is
I met a I met someone who was like yeah
my memory's been crapped since I got
covered I'm like wait is this real I
looked it up yeah apparently you can
some people got memory issues Jesus if
you've got long covered holy [__] I was
just always done so like it actually
didn't do anything
yeah let me rephrase the question what
are some things to avoid to have a
successful anime production in your
opinion uh to have a well communication
um everything everything yeah right I
mean to you have to communicate you
can't refuse to communicate I mean you
constantly have to be keep on up up on
everything information I feel that
applies to just most businesses though
right it's like one miscommunication and
just [__] goes array yeah yeah I I
remember like growing up
is I remember growing up like in
University or something like that yeah
every every job would be picking up the
communication skills yeah and I remember
always thinking as a teenager I'm like
what what [__] skills is there is
there to do just just talk bro just talk
yeah you all at every job interviews how
good are your Communications yeah I'm
like I know English
yeah but like yeah especially working in
like I worked as like a project
management I realized oh communication
is definitely a skill and there are some
people that suck at it
um and you have no idea how much a
project can go wrong whether it be an
animation or any kind of other project
you're managing just because people
don't feel like talking about it yeah
people just don't talk about everything
um and I kind of I can only imagine with
how many moving Parts there are in the
animation industry